welcome to this video playing
international master misko meniscal from
Slovakia ok let's see i have not played
him before he got a name Milan haha
twenty-two-year-old Bratislava ok don't
know the guy let's see a Queens gambit i
takes them now mmhmm yeah soft spot in
my repertoire I don't really don't
really have a great line against that or
any line let's try this gambit this
gambit continuation which is some is at
least interesting gives white some some
initiative
what has very good good piece play and
this threatening queen position is
really really giving some compensation I
guess I guess this makes sense
preventing casa di this looks this looks
really dangerous I don't really know
that too well but and if this is what
black is getting in this line it looks
great it's probably probably some better
some better defense i mean this this
looks dangerous at least okay so Luke
has just ruled e1 keeping it keeping it
simple he probably wants to go he wants
to go Quincy six and Bishop d7 this kind
of this kind of thing hmm
maybe maybe just threaten Ruby one look
like a six he can play but it's nothing
that he particularly likes to do i guess
i can think about Luke to you one Queen
c6 Bishop b5 a b.a b.a twins the Queen
takes on c6 not sure that I win the game
though okay this is probably right in
any case Bishop b5 a Bab rook a 18 x e6
group takes d1 Quint XD 1p takes c6
Queen a for Queen a force very strong so
I probably should do that I think a be a
be any other Queen why take the rook
very it's very very typical tactical
motif Queen takes rook takes I mean c8
is just I don't see how he covers it so
it's it's about the position yeah this
is this position take the f Queen a for
Queen a four-strong you cannot castle
and I don't think you can avoid the
research raid takes Queen a4 I thought
was so strong or is this is this i think
it's strong there should be seven queen
a7 is useless yeah i know i have to
check i have the check here check and
Bishop g5 castles bishop d aid it's
really it's really just just winning
material he does not have anything in
terms of a pin also can just go here and
take on 1c7 black resigns sure unless
the computer proves me otherwise this
looked like quite a good game I hope I
mean this little if definitely is a very
substantial compensation I mean I I
don't really think I don't really know
what black must do but this cannot be
the the way to defend my computer is
giving white a very big advantage
already this and now yeah this is a this
is a question the computer wants to do
not this move wants to play this this
would be one I mean I mean the the
difference in peace activity is simply a
simply astonishing basics and now it
wants to do something like this yeah
it's a fantastic position for wide got
all pieces in play and black Issa
uncoordinated but is there something
wrong with my approach maybe am gamble
a4 is a move that is really setting up
what was happening in the game the comp
goes c6 and Quincy 7 now with the 1.6
for wild but this winning notice is
winning right yeah the computer also
check computer agrees that wide wins
very good and now Queen am the best I
thought that the toughest would be king
d7 here actually but ok white white must
be winning him that's a that's quite
quite clear Queen f4 probably it's a
it's still a matter of coordination I
mean
think something like this is winning
winning even more material here and this
this wins with the h-bond coming Wow
nice at tech okay thanks for watching